- [Voiceover] We have a passage here,
this passage is adapted
from Richard Florida,
"The Great Reset."
I've been finding these
passages interesting
so I'm excited about this.
In today's idea-driven economy,
the cost of time is what really matters.
With the constant pressure to innovate,
it makes little sense to waste
countless collective hours commuting.
So, the most efficient
and productive regions
are those in which people
are thinking and working -
not sitting in traffic.
The auto-dependent transportation system
has reached its limit in most
major cities and megaregions.
Commuting by car
is among the least efficient
of all our activities -
not to mention among the least enjoyable,
according to detailed research
by the Nobel Prize-winning
economist Daniel Kahneman
and his colleagues.
Though one might think
that the economic crisis beginning in 2007
would have reduced traffic
(high unemployment means fewer workers
travelling to and from work),
the opposite has been true.
Average commutes have lengthened,
and congestion has gotten
worse, if anything.
The average commute rose in 2008
to 25.5 minutes,
"erasing years of decreases
"to stand at the level of 2000,
"as people had to leave their homes
"earlier in the morning
"to pick up friends for their ride to work
"or to catch a bus or subway train,"
according to the US Census
Bureau, which collects figures.
So this right here is
I guess a direct quote
from the US Census Bureau.
And those are average figures.
Commutes are far longer in
the big West Coast cities
of Los Angeles and San Francisco
and the East Coast cities of New York,
Philadelphia, Baltimore
and Washington, DC.
In many of these cities,
gridlock has become the norm,
not just at rush hour
but all day, everyday.
The costs are astounding.
In Los Angeles, congestion eats up
more than 485 million
working hours a year;
that's 70 hours or nearly two weeks,
of full-time work per commuter.
In DC, the time cost of
congestion is 62 hours
per worker per year.
In New York it is 44 hours.
Average it out,
and the time cost across
America's 13 biggest city-regions
is 51 hours per worker per year.
Across the country,
commuting wastes 4.2 billion hours
of work time annually -
nearly a full workweek for every commuter.
The overall cost to the US economy
is nearly $90 billion
when lost productivity and wasted fuel
are taken into account.
At the Martin Prosperity
Institute, we calculate,
so I guess that's where he works,
we calculate that every minute
shaved off America's commuting time
is worth $19.5 billion
in value added to the economy.
The numbers add up fast:
five minutes is worth $97.7 billion;
10 minutes, $195 billion;
15 minutes, $292 billion.
It's ironic that so many
people still believe
the main remedy for traffic congestion
is to build more roads and highways,
which of course only
makes the problem worse.
New roads generate higher
levels of "induced traffic,"
that is, new roads just
invite drivers to drive more
and lure people who take mass transit
back to their cars.
Eventually, we end up
with more clogged roads
rather than a long-term
improvement in traffic flow.
The coming decades will likely see
more intense clustering of jobs,
innovation, and productivity
in a smaller number of bigger
cities and city-regions.
Some regions could end up bloated
beyond the capacity of
their infrastructure,
while others struggle,
their promise stymied by inadequate human
or other resources.
All right, so this guy,
he is very anti-traffic,
very anti-long-commute-times
and it seem like he
doesn't think the solution
is more roads,
because he thinks that will
just get more people driving.
We have a chart here, The
Most Congested Cities in 2011,
Yearly Hours of Delay
per Automobile Commuter.
Year hours of delay.
Yearly hours of delay
per automobile commuter.
Here we see DC is actually
at the top right over here,
at least for this list
Phoenix is at the bottom,
although there's probably
many other cities
if we were to keep listing them,
these are the biggest cities,
the most congested cities in 2011.
The average of these very large cities,
look it's a little over 50
hours, they talk about that.
A normal workweek is roughly 40 hours
so it's saying the average commuter
is spending over a week of worth of work
sitting in their car,
sitting in traffic maybe
getting stresses and frustrated.
This is the argument of this passage.
Looking forward to doing the questions.